was ich nicht verstehe und was mich
wirklich traurig und wütend macht ist
folgendes wir haben eine Partei die
bezeichnete Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem Verdachtsfall in Thüringen
als gesichert rechtsextrem die
sogenannten gemäßigten sind fast alle
rausgeschmissen aus dem Bundesvorstand
der intellektuelle Geist ist
rechtsextrem und westdeutsch und das
also deutsche Landbevölkerung die eher
illiberal ist was Homosexualität und so
weiter angeht eine Frau toll findet
lesbisch ist in der Schweiz wohnt und
kann sich ganz anders verhält als sie
auftritt dass sie sozusagen das
irgendwie gut finden ist mehr wirklich
ein Rätsel und das macht mich richtig
wütend
[Musik]